The circulatory system, accepted as a fact for only three short centuries.
Before that, the Belgian anatomist, Andreas Vassale, first dared to speak of it in 1543.
The result? He was condemned to be burnt at the stake.
He was saved from the Inquisition in the nick of time by a powerful friend, Philip II of Spain.
Ten years later, Michel Servette, a Spaniard, dared to speak of the circulatory system.
But he had no king to protect him, so he died at the stake.
In 1628, when William Harvey, an Englishman, tried to explain the circulatory system, he was ridiculed.
Years later, the dean of the Paris School of Medicine, Dr. Guy Patung, is lecturing.
No, gentlemen, this is sheer nonsense, for as demonstrated by our great master, the Greek anatomist Galean, there can be no circulation of the blood.
Absolute nonsense, I don't believe it, not a word.
And yet, there is a circulatory system.
Driven by the heart.
My friends, you'll soon find out for yourselves.
The heart is a fascinating organ.
Why, with the blood it pumps during one lifetime,
you could fill a 200 million liter vat.
Yet it's no bigger than a human fist.
It's amazing, that is absolutely fascinating organ.
You'll see what goes on there is almost magical.
Believe me, my friend.
It could be a bit alarming, but fascinating all the same.
Remember, we've come all the way from the very tips of the feet.
And as you know, that is our job.
They need our oxygen to function.
down there. They also need us to carry away their carbon dioxide. Everything passes through
the heart. This is actually a closed circuit.
I don't like this carbon dioxide. It really weighs me down.
This vein in the prize you to shut your baskets. We are very close to the heart now.
Nose is full. Sense of duty.
Last, my friends, in the right oracle, one of the four chambers of the heart.
See how magnificent our surroundings are. Our colleagues over there have come from the
upper part of the body.
From the head to the arm.
From that path and the one we've followed, we bring all the blood in the body to this one chamber.
Then we'll be off to the lungs again.
Going to get there?
Come.
What on earth is that loud noise?
Take a look.
Do you see what all the noise was?
Those three flaps form the tricuspid valve.
And we're going through it in a minute.
Quick, come over here with me.
Otherwise, we'll all be swept away when they open again.
Hold on tight, everybody.
Through there is one of the lower chambers of the heart, the right ventricle.
It's even more impressive.
Sistole is starting.
Everyone, this time there's no escape.
Worry, little one.
Millions of us do it every time the heart beats our life.
The architecture is to stand up to anything.
Just think, these pillars will withstand three billion heartbeats in one lifetime.
Three billion heartbeats?
Yes.
Quickly, this is really something to see.
We will just have time before another sistole.
It's time is everyone ready don't either you know it's a mystery again. It was really sensational
This is a one-way street, but don't you worry
We'll soon be going back to the heart just a short trip to the lungs and back
It's called the short pulmonary cycle in any case. I'm afraid. I still don't understand a thing
It's really quite easy
We were on the long systemic cycle round the feet and the organs and the head and then we entered the heart from the right
And now, we are making our way from the heart to the lungs to drop our load and stock up with oxygen.
Then we will come back to the left side of the heart so that we can be sent to carry oxygen to all parts of the body.
Do you see now?
Short cycle take, Professor.
We cover 35 centimeters a second. You can work it out.
Control 8, get me headquarters fast!
Don't bother them, my friend.
We'll handle this. Come on, guys, attack!
In his diet, probably. But what you see here is nothing compared to what I've seen.
Worse than this?
Indeed, if the passage is blocked, it means a coronary thrombosis, and that is very serious.
How would you like me to tell you a story now?
Good, that will give me time for a little rest.
One day, in one of my former lives, I was working with my fellow corpuscles in a body which was not very healthy.
I'm afraid this looks serious.
Forget it, although it's our duty.
What exactly did you feel?
Sharp pains like needles in my chest, Doctor, and also in my left arm.
In spasms?
That's correct, yes. In spasms, and I get out of breath over nothing at all.
You've been overdoing it. Your circulation's in a very bad way, you know.
Oh, so that's all it is.
What do you mean, that's all? You're headed for disaster if you don't take serious steps now.
You must cut out all tobacco, all alcohol, all salt, all fats, everything.
A very strict diet, you understand?
Yeah. Alcohol.
No more fats, he said.
No more tobacco.
I forgot.
No smoke without fire.
As expected, it ended in a coronary thrombosis.
Obviously, when the fats built up, the passageways became completely blocked.
We couldn't get through anymore.
That's what a thrombosis is.
Oh, he survived it all right, but it wasn't easy.
Human beings aren't always the most sensible of creatures.
Right, everyone.
I think we've wasted enough time.
Now we're heading for the alveoli.
Dear professor, this carbon dioxide is getting me down.
The alveoli soon will have plenty of pure air again.
Enough now, boys and girls. We must get on with our work.
Yes, my friends, going through those capillaries is not much fun.
See all these little veins?
They're going to join up with us to form the large pulmonary vein, which will take us back to the heart.
Bring along there, this way.
Tabling.
It serves the entire body.
When there's an emergency like this one, it steps up its rhythm.
to send reinforcements where they are needed.
I mean, don't you think that is a wonderful mechanism?
- Why can't we just get on with our work
without the heart, Professor Globus?
- Because only the heart has the strength
to send us where we have to go.
Without it, the circulation would stop
and everything would die for lack of nourishment.
You understand?
- Well, personally speaking,
I don't really understand a thing.
- Oh, don't start that again.
- Now come to the end of the short cycle again.
Soon we'll be in the heart once more
on the left side this time.
If I'm not in error.
I'm very sorry to interrupt, but unless I'm mistaken, that's a customer of mine down there.
Let's get it over with then, my children.
Something else, wasn't it?
That's where we came from, the right lung.
And over there, our friends were arriving from the left lung.
Everyone get ready to go down into the lower chamber now.
It's called the left ventricle.
This is our last jump.
Wonderful, don't you think?
Most powerful of the four chambers of the heart.
From here, we will set off on our longest journey.
They're full, but frightening.
Yes, that's right.
Absolutely right!
Exactly!
I've said it.
That's because the left ventricle is seven times more powerful than the right.
Can you believe that it takes much more strength to send us into the general circulatory system?
It's a very long journey.
Now, move along there.
He won't be going to the right arm.
Going to the brain, either.
It is fascinating.
Ah, well, maybe next time.
Now, we're off on the grand tour.
The abdomen, the liver, the spleen, the intestines, maybe the legs.
So, chins up and forward march.
It is a fascinating organ.
Yes, absolutely fascinating.
Professor, dear, does your heart ever rest at all?
No, it's not made for peace and quiet.
It's made for emotions, feelings, love.
In short, everything that makes life worth living.
Yes, the heart is a simply fascinating organ.
Heart.
Size, 10 centimeters by 15.
Mass, 300 grams.
Flow rate, 5 liters of blood per minute, 8,000 liters per day, and over 200 million liters in one man's lifetime.
The heart, fascinating organ.